- OK, so if business is a sport—
- Yep.
- Tell me your NBA comparison.
Who are you in the sport of business?
- I'm Wilt. I'm Jordan.
I'm LeBron. I'm Luka.
- [Laughing]
- I'm Dirk. I'm Magic. I'm Bird, all rolled into one.
- You're all of it, yeah.
- Rolled into one.
- All into one!
- All into one! You can't touch me!
- I love that.
The man himself!
- What's up?
- What's up, Mark? How you doin'?
- I'm great. How are you, Taylor?
- I'm so good.
You know, normally I would say, "Welcome,"
but we're doing this in your domain.
- Welcome!
- Yeah, I'm so happy to be here.
So this is, what, admin, sales?
- Yeah,
so, there's two sides.
This is the back office side.
- OK.
- And then on the other side is the practice
facility and the front office side.
- Yeah, no, it's so beautiful.
I was just saying to Jackie, I was like,
it looks like a startup. Like, the layout of it.
- Yeah, it does.
- It's very open.
- That's the whole idea.
- You did that on purpose?
- Yeah, I do it for all my companies.
- Yeah.
- It's not like real fancy or anything.
You know, I'm not big on
spending money on furniture or offices.
- Right.
- I'd rather put it on the court.
- Yeah, no, it's cool.
- Yeah.
- It's very hip in here.
OK, so the last time I saw you—I saw you,
but you didn't see me. It was after,
I think, Game 5 of
Western Conference Finals.
And it was like, you,
Dirk, Luka, Chet Holmgren, all talking in the hallway.
- Oh, after the game, yeah.
- Yes. Everyone's snapping pics.
What do you remember about that
conversation with all those guys?
- Just trying to come down
from being pissed off. [Laughing]
- Yeah, yeah, I'm sure.
- You know,
but yeah, I mean, seeing Dirk
and Luka is always fun.
Met Chet for the first time, and, you know,
any kid—that was predraft,
so any kid coming in
is always excited and—
- Yeah.
- Obviously, you know, him meeting Dirk and Luka,
he didn't care about me.
He didn't even know I was there.
- [Laughing] Yeah. He's like, "I just wanna meet these guys."
- These guys, yeah.
- So when I see Luka and Dirk,
and give me your thought on this,
cuz I go back and forth on it all the time.
I'm like, is it unfair the way that, like, fans
and the media
almost put on Luka, like, "Well,
you have to be what Dirk was.
That's what you have to
mean to the Mavericks."
- Yeah, it is a little bit unfair,
but the good news is
they've got similar personalities
in a lot of respects.
If you knew Dirk when he was 21, 22, 23,
you would not—like, if they looked the same
and you would just judge their actions—
- Yeah.
- They're a lot the same
- In what ways?
- Just their attitude
towards life,
having fun, focus on the game.
So, work hard, play hard basically.
- Yeah.
- But they kinda pick their spots.
And, you know,
Dirk, it was a little bit more difficult
because he had more challenges
with the language than Luka does.
Luka speaks, like, 30 languages.
But they're so similar in
so many respects.
- Yeah, absolutely.
And I also think it seems like Dirk
genuinely is like a mentor to Luka.
- Oh, yeah, without question.
- Yeah.
- I mean, they love each other.
They're close. I mean—
- Yeah.
- You know, I've been on
some of the text chains. They're insane,
first of all,
but they really do care for each other.
It's not like, "Oh, the cameras are on.
Let me give you a big hug."
- Mmhmm.
- They'll spend time together. They'll get together here.
They'll get together in Europe.
They'll get together wherever they can.
They're just two good guys hanging out.
- Yeah.
So when I spoke to you after the bubble,
we were talking about Luka
for a little bit.
- Mmhmm.
- And you said that you had asked him, "OK,
what are you gonna add to your game
this offseason?"
And at that time, it was that he wanted a left hand—
- Right, his left, yeah.
- And wanted to be able to finish.
- Yeah.
- And that was what he added in the bubble season.
- Without question, yeah.
- So what have—have you asked him that question yet?
- Yep, but I can't tell you.
- What?!
Why?! You told me last time!
- No, I know! Cuz, I can't tell you.
- OK.
- But, yeah, it was, it was crazy what
we talked about adding, and so we'll see.
- OK.
- I don't want to, I don't want to jinx him.
But if you see something and you're going,
"Where the hell did that come from?"
You'll know that's what it was.
- OK,
just tell me, like, is it a move—?
- Yeah.
- Is it just a—OK.
- It's a move. It's a shot.
- OK. So what would you want him to add?
- That shot,
because it's insane.
So two things that, you know,
the move that will not be disclosed.
And I think, I think he's gonna learn
how to use the backboard.
I think that's gonna be a thing
in the NBA where, you know, you see guys
who are athletic throwing the ball off
the backboard and finishing with the dunk.
But I think strategically,
you're gonna see it added into the NBA,
and I think Luka's gonna benefit,
hopefully will benefit.
So that's kinda the weird stuff
I talk to him about.
- Yeah.
- Like, you know,
it's like stuff that is so bizarre
that nobody else would really consider
or do it.
- Yeah.
- But that's the stuff I like to talk about.
- OK, give me another example
of the weird stuff.
- No, I mean, that's as weird as it gets.
Like, "Luka, if you're down in the paint
and you don't have what you want and
you're doing all your stuff, just toss it up
against the backboard. Get it back,
reset the three-second clock and go back to work, you know?
- Yeah.
- And, you know, he kinda rolls his eyes,
but we'll see what happens.
- Yeah. I mean, I love that
that's your offseason question
to Luka. It's like, "What are we going to see
you add next season?" Cuz you said,
you know, the greats every season—
- Every year.
- They come back with something new.
- Dirk would,
you know, we always had that conversation,
and Dirk wouldn't tell me. He would just show
me, you know? He said, "Just watch.
I'm working."
You know, everybody
that's ever been really, really good
that we've had here
has always come back with something more.
And that's what makes him great.
Luka hasn't hit his ceiling yet.
Not even close.
- Yeah. So what is that?
What is that Luka ceiling?
- I mean, you know, he keeps on
getting a stronger
and stronger feel for the game
and his teammates
and integrating it all together.
You know, there's one thing to be great and
put up points, assists, rebounds, etc.
It's a whole 'nother thing to understand
the time and place
during any game to know
what needs to happen with your teammates.
And I still, I think he's good at it, but
he's on his way to becoming great at it.
- Mmhmm.
- There aren't a lotta guys in this league that
can lift their teammates
to a whole 'nother complete level.
Lots of guys can take over a game, but
there aren't a lotta guys that can help
their teammates take over a game or pick
which teammate will take over a game,
or which combination of teammates will take
over a game on both sides of the ball.
And Luka's got that unique ability.
- What game this past season
did you see that the most?
- Phoenix Game 7.
- Yeahhh!
- I mean, that was just—
I'm, you know, it was just like,
"Don't pinch me," you know? It was just,
you know, where that first half,
it was his game.
And then the second half it was, OK,
let's let our guys do their thing and
and have their role and amplify their role
and make them better.
- Yeah.
- You know,
people underestimate the value of a player
who can make his teammates better.
You know, I think LeBron's like that.
But there aren't aren't many
where you just say,
you know, it doesn't really matter
who you put around him.
Dirk was like that.
You know,
a lotta people said prior
to our championship season,
you know,
there was Dirk and Manny, Moe and Jack,
you know? And we kept on winning 50 games
and making the playoffs.
And so it takes a really special NBA
player to be able to make everybody around
you better.
- Yeah. I mean, and when you talk about that series,
obviously a lotta discourse
right now about the fact that you all
are gonna match up again next season.
- Yep.
- But what did you learn about
Luka and Devin Booker in that series?
- I mean, I'm not gonna talk about Book.
You know, it's tough when,
you know, we've been on both sides.
We lost in the conference finals.
- Yeah.
- So, you know, he's a great player,
and he'll do great things.
But, you know, Luka's got that eye of the
Luka. I'm not even gonna say eye of the tiger,
but he just gets that,
you know, that look in his eye where,
"OK, this is what I'm gonna do."
- Mmhmm.
- You know, and whatever it takes.
And he just reads the game so well,
he doesn't have—
you know, some guys have two spots
on the court, right?
Or they have one thing
that they'll do all the time,
or they'll get to the left
and they'll get a shot.
Luka could be anywhere, anyhow.
You don't know what he's gonna do.
Now, he likes the step-back three-pointer,
but he can be anywhere on the court
and he's gonna be dangerous.
- Can you always, like,
see when that look comes from him?
- Well, it depends on the game, right?
- Yeah.
- Because there's some games where it's hard,
and, you know,
people don't realize the mental challenge
to play 82 games,
that, you know, you're not gonna
get up at the same level for every game.
You're gonna play hard, you know, but it's—you
know, guys don't always respect
every team at the same level
or every player at the same level.
And so when Luka really feels
that there's a challenge,
I know, you know, he's goin' to work.
- Yeah.
- And when he doesn't feel
there's as much of a challenge, you know,
he'll—that's games where
he'll like, OK, go to his teammates and say,
"This is your chance," right?
- Mmhmm.
- "We're gonna let you shine, Doe-Doe [Dorian Finney-Smith].
We're gonna let you shine, Maxi [Kleber]." Whoever
it may be.
- Yeah.
So I think you may have touched
on the answer for this a bit,
but I wanna get your perspective on it.
We talk a lot about what's a star.
We talk about what's a superstar.
- Yeah.
- To you, what is the difference, and where is Luka
right now?
- "Star" is somebody who can help the team win."
A superstar is somebody
who can will his team to win.
- Mmhmm.
- You know, when it's not working,
you find there's
a superstar will find a way to win
the game on either side of the court.
You know,
there are a lot of great players.
There are a lot of stars.
But come crunch time,
they might not want the ball.
They might not even be able
to get a shot off.
And that's where the league
has changed a lot.
And that's one of the reasons
we were so excited to trade to draft Luka,
because in my—in our—opinion,
the best players
are the ones that can bring the ball up
the court and impact the game
however they need to. Passing, shooting,
rebounding, whatever.
Whereas with other players
who may be stars,
they need somebody else
to get them to their their spots
or they need somebody
to get them the ball.
And in this day and age,
with all the spacing that we have,
you know, when that person
is the same person, right?
They can be unstoppable.
- Yeah. And where do you feel like
Luka is at this moment?
How does he make the jump?
- I think he's there, you know,
and it's not about making the jump.
He is a superstar, right?
- Mmhmm.
- It's a question of, you know,
can he be one of the all time greats?
And I think he's showing everybody
that he can,
and he is,
and it's just a question of how good.
- Yeah.
So for you, I mean, obviously,
this is a large part of the job for you
when you talk about what do we need to do
to get this next championship,
how do all these things fit?
- Sure, sure.
- Does Luka right now have all the pieces
around him to win a championship?
- Yeah.
I mean, if we you know,
when we lost in the conference finals,
I don't think it was for lack of talent.
I think
the Warriors deserve a lot of credit
because they had played together so long.
Their execution was phenomenal, right?
- Yeah.
- The way they ran their offense,
knowing exactly where the ball was going,
the way they had their rotations
defensively, you know, knowing who to get,
who to push where and how to prevent
them, prevent guys from being comfortable.
That wasn't as much talent
as it was corporate knowledge.
- Mmhmm.
- You know, the experience of having played
together for all those years
and been in crunch situations, knowing
what to do. We hadn't been there yet,
you know? And so, we had been
out of the first round in 10 years.
- Yeah.
- And so a lot of it was execution.
And when you're talking to our guys
during the series,
that was the thing that kept on
coming up, right?
- Yeah.
- The Warriors knew
where to be on both sides of the ball,
no matter how we adjusted,
cuz the teams we had played before hadn't
had been as good at adjustments.
And so I think for us it's not so much
we need that second star or whatever.
It's more let's just get some time,
you know, and experience in crunch
time situations in the playoffs
and that'll pay off.
- But see, that's the thing. I agree.
I think, number one, people
undervalue experience and they're not—
but it's almost like a chicken
and an egg thing,
because to get the experience,
You gotta get the experience.
- Yeah, of course. And it's hard.
- So it's like, how do you simulate that?
- No, you can't simulate it.
You gotta be there, right?
I mean, if you look at the Celtics
Warriors in the Finals, you could see that
the Celtics had great talent,
but the Warriors just outexecuted them,
the same thing they did to us.
They didn't shoot them,
you know. They didn't,
but they went with the guy,
they got the guy who was hot, open,
got their looks.
And, you know, it was just guys
who had knew their roles,
like an Andrew Wiggins, right?
I think he was the one who beat us.
And I told him that after the series,
you know? It's like,
we knew what to expect from Klay
and from Steph and from Draymond,
you know, we didn't know what to expect
or how Wiggs would step up, and he did.
- Yeah.
- And that's what it comes down to
in that type of series.
The team understanding, everybody
understanding the roles,
being able to execute
on what the coach puts out there for you
and having guys you might call "role
players" step up when the time is right.
- Yeah, I love that.
How did Andrew react when you told him?
- He said, "Thank you, man."
You know, and then he went to celebrate.
We're going to the Finals.
- [Laughs] You're like, "I don't care.
Yeah, I know. We won."
And he just moves on.
- Yeah.
- OK
well, so speaking of championships,
obviously Dirk, such a cornerstone here.
I read he's gonna have an
office somewhere.
- Yeah, it's back on the other side.
Yeah, he does have an office.
- Yeah.
- So does the office come with,
like, an expanded role?
Is he gonna be like, very involved?
- Whatever he wants.
- Dirk is you know, he does
whatever he wants.
- Totally.
- Yeah. It's not like, "Dirk,
what do you wanna do?"
It's just like, "OK, do what you wanna do."
- Yeah.
He's, I mean, he's a legacy, you know,
he knows the door is open.
We talk all the time.
So it's just, you know, after being,
you know, on the road
for 21 years, you want to spend some time
with your family and all that.
- Yeah.
- So he he'll pick his time
when the time is right.
But we talk and he's not shy
about sharing his opinion.
- Yeah. He's like, "This is what I want."
- And I think you said he's
just been bugging you about the statue.
"When is it coming? When's the unveiling?"
- It's coming. It's coming this year.
- OK.
It is absolutely coming this year.
- Absolutely coming this year.
- So a conversation we were having
actually is like, what do you think
is the criteria
to get a statue at a place?
- You have to stay there.
It's about being there,
about being a superstar,
leading the team to a championship
and being there
for an extended period of time.
- Yes.
- You know,
that's key, because you know, it's
not just about what you do on the court.
It's about what you do in the community.
It's about being part of the
fabric of an organization.
During and
after your playing time, and
Dirk exemplifies that.
- Absolutely. OK,
give me to other players around the league
that you believe will have statues
at their respective arenas.
- I mean, LeBron obviously, and Steph.
- Deservedly so.
- Yeah, absolutely.
And I was actually just talking about this,
I know I asked for NBA, but I'm like,
the Storm have to give Sue a statue.
- Yeah, of course. How long has he been there?
Twenty years?
- Yeah, I'm like this is, she
is the Seattle Storm.
- She's the WNBA.
- Yeah, and the thing with statues though,
I'm like, OK,
they have to look exactly like the person.
That would make me nervous!
- No it's not gonna work that way.
It's not ever gonna work that way.
- Yeah, absolutely.
OK,
So I wanna talk a little bit about
Jalen Brunson, because I know you said
obviously there's no hard feelings
between you guys, you're excited for him.
But I have a lot of players on this show
that talk about
what it's like to be traded away
or like it being a business.
I don't always have an owner.
Tell me what that moment is like.
So what emotion do you tie to
Jalen Brunson deciding to not stay?
- I mean, it's weird because
we kinda knew it was happening.
There was a whole confluence of issues
coming along after
we got eliminated from the playoffs
and there's just hint after hint after hint.
So by the time it happened, you know,
we knew he'd already broken up with us.
And so it was just a matter
of who else he was gonna start dating.
- Yeah.
- You know? And so, yeah.
So it wasn't like, "Oh no, oh my goodness,
I can't believe this is happening."
It was like, "OK, it's coming."
- Yeah.
It's like you felt it.
- When you say it was hint after hint after hint.
What do you mean by that?
- You know. Um, you
know, it's just there are, you know,
you can just tell, that's all.
There are certain moves
that other teams were making,
you know, to open up a cap room.
And so that, you know, made it
kind of obvious where he was going.
- Yeah.
- And that's the way it played out.
What kind of position does that put you in
when you feel it?
- Um, look, it's
part of the game, you know. It's
the same position is going into a trade
or going into the trade deadline.
You know, players get nervous,
and rightfully so, because you just never
know.
You know, having been through 20-plus
trade deadlines now,
99.99 percent of proposed trades don't happen.
And 95 percent of the ones that you think
are going to happen still don't happen.
But in this day and age of social media,
everything gets reported
as if it's a done deal.
- Yeah.
- And so it's no different than players,
you know, feeling that those butterflies
and everything, you know,
you don't want it to happen,
like with JB leaving, but
you can't tell a player
it's just a business.
And then when it happens to you say it's
not a business, it's on the player.
No, it goes both ways.
That's the way it is
- Yeah, I would
think, and correct me if I'm wrong,
you feel like and from all the things
I've watched from you,
you're a competitive person.
- Yeah, of course. Yeah.
- So you're like, "Well, I want to win."
- Yeah.
- "I want this to be,
you know, all of these things."
So I'm just curious for you,
is it easy for you to, like, let go of
when something doesn't go
your way? Do you, like, sit on it?
- Depends on what it is.
- So there's certain things I have control
over. If I have any type of control?
- Yeah.
- It's on. Right?
If I don't have any control,
like something like this,
you gotta move on, you know?
And so, in the game
of basketball there's always context.
You know, there's five guys on the court,
there's only one ball, it's a 48 minute
game and all the playing time
and all the roles get adjusted.
So talk to Nico, talk to J. Kidd,
and, you know, we think we're gonna
have a better team.
And that's no disrespect to Jalen, right?
- Mmhmm.
- Jalen had an amazing role, but adding
Christian Wood, you know, having Spencer,
you know, further away from his injury
and more comfortable in their roles.
I mean, for us to to pick up the,
you know, the guys that we did
and go to the Western Conference
Finals, that says a lot.
And so, and obviously JB was a big part.
But I think, you know, JB's
primary role for us was scoring,
and I think we more than compensated
and made up for that with Christian.
- Yeah.
So you feel like this Mavericks team
we'll see next season is a better team than the—
- Yeah, without question.
Because one of our real failings
last year was rebounding and shot-blocking
and having—you know, and when we played
five out, we could play that with Max,
meaning, you know, all five players out
beyond the three-point line.
But we'll be even better at it with Christian.
- Yeah.
- And with Maxi
to come off the bench to support that,
I think we'll be a much better team,
which will open up more space for Luka,
and the ball will move a little bit more.
- Yeah. Well, for someone who,
you talk about,
you know, the things you can control
versus things you don't,
I would assume you don't really like to
not to be in control of things.
- Well, of course.
- Yeah. Like, you wanna be able to control things.
So obviously when you're sitting
watching the game,
you can't do anything—
- Nope.
- Cuz they're just playing.
- Right.
- So when you're watching,
like, what percentage of the game is fun?
What percentage is stress? Like, what's that—
- 99.99 percent stress—
- OK.
- Until we've won.
- Yeah.
- People don't realize that because—it's just like, people see me
screaming and yelling,
and it's just like it's stress relief.
- Mmhmm.
- You know?
And they'll see me after a big game
where we've won,
and I'm just hoopin' and hollerin'
because that's letting all the stress out,
you know?
And particularly in the playoffs,
where there's so much at stake.
During the regular season,
there's another game maybe. You know,
there's a lot of consequences to this game,
and it's big,
but during the playoffs, it's all stress.
- Yeah.
- 100 percent stress.
- Yeah, I would think so.
And I think, you know,
you broke an 11-year drought—
- Yep.
- You know, of not winning a playoff series.
I'm sure that was a lot of stress.
- A lotta stress, yes.
- Yeah.
- So when that shot didn't go in from
Bogdanovic from Utah, you have no idea.
No idea.
- [Laughing] Yeah.
- It was just like the skies parted,
and the sun was shining,
and the entire organization and city were like, "[Exhaling]."
- "We did it!"
- Yeah.
- But then, you know, and then,
you know, going to Phoenix
and getting blown out
those first two games.
And I remember being next to the bench,
and I wasn't really paying attention
to the fans.
And I went to Darrell,
"What are they saying?" They're like, "They're
chanting 'Suns in four, Suns in four.''
And I'm like, "Ohhh, OK, we'll see about that."
- Yeah.
- You know?
And so, yeah, it's just, it's all stress, Taylor. All stress.
- No, I would assume so.
So of those 11 years,
which year was the hardest?
- I'd say the year we trade—
when we brought in Harrison
and Andrew Bogut and—who
else did we have?
We had CP25,
we had Chandler Parsons and Monta,
I think, and I thought
we were gonna have a good team,
and it just didn't turn out.
And Deron Williams,
that's who we brought in.
- Yeah.
- And it just didn't turn out that way.
So when we started trading everybody,
that was, OK, it's time to rebuild.
You know, we start going young.
And so that was hard
cuz we had won 50 games
I don't even know how many years,
and I'd never had a losing season.
- Yeah.
- You know?
- Which is—like, that's so impressive, I hope you—
- Yeah, well…well, that's Dirk, right?
- Yeah.
- And so, that's the definition of a superstar.
- Yup.
- Right? When you're always gonna win 50 games
and not have losing seasons.
And so that was the toughest
because I really thought
we were gonna move forward.
- Yeah.
So I was talking to my producer, Rocky, and
she was telling me about a friend, a conversation
she had with her friend, just about,
like, what this team means for you.
So is this team an investment?
Is it a passion?
Is it a challenge?
How do you think about the team?
- I'm a "ball is life" guy,
you know? Literally, like, my stress
release is going in my backyard
and getting up shots and,
you know, working on my form,
you know, or going to play pickup,
you know?
- Yeah.
- You know, to tell you
my feelings on basketball,
I got a hard workout in Saturday morning.
And these guys, you know,
all but maybe one was a lot, like, lot
younger than me. Like a third my age.
And they're like, "We need one."
And I'm like, so tired,
and I'm just so beat up.
- Yeah.
- But when you get, you know,
when you're walking by a court
and they say, "We need one"—
- You're like—
- You gotta play, right?
I don't care what it is.
- "That's me!
Pick me."
- You could have crutches,
and you gotta put 'em down and say—
- Yeah.
- "I'm gonna play."
And so, yeah, that's my attitude towards
basketball, and that's the connection.
And then owning the team and
the financial side of it's secondary.
- Yeah. OK.
You've said that
business is the ultimate sport.
- Yeah, it is.
- Explain what you mean by that.
You know, I mean, basketball,
you play 82 games plus the playoffs.
You know who you're gonna play.
You have time to prepare.
There's an offseason.
You get some time off. In business,
you don't even know who your competition may be.
- Yeah.
- And you're competing with them 24
by seven by 365 by forever.
You know, if I start a business,
and you're in my industry,
I'm coming to kick your ass.
- Yeah.
- And if you start a business, and you're in
my industry, I'm coming to kick your ass,
right?
And so that's why I keep
on, you know, investing in companies,
starting companies, whatever it may be,
because that competitive side of me,
that's where the juices flow.
- Yeah.
- And it's just that ongoing, nonstop intellectual challenge
to be great at whatever industry I'm in.
- Mmhmm. OK—
- Doesn't always work.
- Yeah.
- But yeah.
- But your goal is to be great.
- Yeah, not gonna go 82-0 in business either, so.
- Yeah. OK, so if business is a sport—
- Yeah.
- Tell me your NBA comparison.
Who are you in the sport of business?
- I'm Wilt. I'm Jordan.
I'm LeBron. I'm Luka.
- [Laughing]
- I'm Dirk. I'm Magic. I'm Bird, all rolled into one.
- You're all of it, yeah.
- Rolled into one.
- All into one! You can't touch me!
- I love that.
And this is, so this is my thing:
I think it's just, it's really interesting
when somebody is good at business
cuz I almost think business
is just, like, this umbrella term.
Everybody thinks they know,
like, what it means to, like,
be an entrepreneur or be a businessman.
But it actually feels like a very specific
thing when you really think about it.
- To be an entrepreneur, yeah.
- Yeah.
- You—
- How would you describe it?
- You've got to be willing to be all
in, right?
You know, some—in sports,
you can be athletically gifted, right?
And that'll carry you a while.
And then, you know,
if you wanna be one of the top 450, it's
not only being athletically gifted, it's,
you know, what's your skill set
and how do you work on it
and what's your basketball
IQ? And business is very similar,
except that it's ever-changing.
- Mmhmm.
You know, we talk about,
you know, three-point
play in analytics changed basketball
some and, you know, less than the big man,
whatever. And business is changing every day.
- Yeah.
- You know, there's some new technology,
there's some new approach,
there's some new rule,
there's some new tax law, whatever it may be.
So the rules are always changing.
And so you've gotta be curious.
You've gotta be agile.
You gotta be able to sell.
You gotta be able to communicate.
You gotta be empathetic.
You've gotta be considerate.
You gotta be nice.
There's all these different skills
that come together
to be good as an entrepreneur.
- Yeah. Well, speaking of that, first off,
as you can see, I like lists.
What three NBA players
would be the best salesmen? And why?
- Um…well, I gotta put Luka.
Luka could sell anything.
That guy is so street smart.
You have no idea.
- Really?
- Oh, my God.
He'll FaceTime me with some—
yeah, never even—
- No, no!
- No, no, no!
- You can't start and stop!
"He'll FaceTime me and—"
- Like, when he's out having fun with something, right?
- Yeah.
- And so with all his boys and whoever out
hanging out with them,
and you'll see a lotta stuff—
- That is not what you were gonna say at first.
- No, but—
- [Laughing]
- You'll see, you know—
- I'm like, "What?"
- Luka's got an amazing team around him,
and so you'll see a lotta really,
really cool tech stuff,
you know, that he helped engineer,
literally,
that is gonna be really cool, so.
- Yeah.
- I say Luka is a great salesperson.
Jordan, obviously, with Jordans,
you know? Michael is great
at what he does there.
- Mmhmm.
- And who out of left field would be a great
sales—who have I dealt with?
We've had—
Theo Pinson—
- Really?
- Probably is, yeah.
- He has a very, like,
vivacious personality.
- Yeah, right. Just like, you know,
and it's funny because he did
this sales thing. I'm like, "Theo,
come on. You're a good salesperson.
Let me give you some hints."
- Yeah.
- You know, and so I think, I think he's
got that potential to be really good.
- Yeah. OK. So speaking of—
- And Spencer, too. Spencer Dinwiddie is really—
- Yeah.
He's a hustler.
- And he already kinda does that.
- All the time.
- Like, he's a big—he's like finance-y and
doing all these, like, innovative things.
- He’s smart.
- He’s very, very smart.
- He's learned how to pull all the pieces together
to leverage his brand to, you know,
enhance his brand. And he digs in.
He doesn't jump from one thing
to a next thing, which is good.
- Yeah.
OK.
So on the subject of business,
what does money start meaning to you
when you've made so much?
- It really depends
where you are in your life, right?
Like, when you're 21, 31,
even 41, it's about potential, right?
As you get older,
it's more about family and impact
because, you know, you start, like—
when I sold my first company, it was like,
Oh, my God, I just want to retire and party
with as many people as possible.
Bought a lifetime pass
in American Airlines
and party like a rock star
and put a lot of rock stars to shame.
And, you know,
and so, you know,
they couldn’t hang with me.
And then bought the Mavs,
and that opened up some other doors.
But then, you know,
you look at other sports teams, is
this what I want to do or whatever else.
But I’ve never been about, like, stuff.
Let me have more houses,
more cars, more money.
Let me be higher on the Forbes 400.
None of that stuff at all
really was important to me.
But as you get older,
you know, and have a family,
then it's like, OK, kids,
and where are they gonna be.
And, you know, my next
dollar is not going to change my life,
but it can change my family's life,
their family's life, their kids’ life
and maybe some other people as well.
And that, at least with me,
that started taking on more importance:
What kind of impact could I have?
- Yeah, absolutely. OK.
I do want to pause and go back to Party
Mark real quick.
- Sure.
- Because in a lot of interviews I've seen,
I've seen you talk about Party Mark.
So tell me the best party story
that you have.
I mean, you said you're
putting rock stars to shame.
I mean, what, what does that mean? Who?
- I mean, there's more
than I could ever possibly tell.
- Tell me the best one.
- So let's put it this way.
If we went out
and I revved it up,
you couldn’t hang.
- Really? You think so?
- No doubt. There is no doubt.
- I don't know.
I've had some fun in my day.
- Yeah.
Trust me.
Yeah.
- Who have you put to shame?
- There's, there's quite a few NBA players
over the years that we've gone toe-to-toe,
and yeah.
I'm not going to name-drop who they are.
- It's only fun when you tell the story.
- I know! But, you know—
- Listen, if you could tell a story
about when Bill Gates took your girl
- Yeah, I know.
- You can tell me one person you partied with.
- Oh, a lot. There's not just one person.
It's just like—one time
we were out for Juwan
Howard’s—
this was when,
when I failed miserably.
I'll give you one when I failed, OK?
So we were out for Juwan Howard's
birthday party in New York City.
It was right before the All-Star break.
We had just played the Knicks, I think,
and we had an extra few days, right?
So we were going to go out. And it was me,
Fin [Michael Finley], Dirk, Nash and I forget
who else. [Al] Whitley maybe? Yeah,
Whits I think and some other folks.
And we went to,
what was it called, Lotus or Lotus
something, and Steve
Nash ended up meeting his then-wife.
That's how crazy the night was.
- Oh, wow.
- But there was a,
there was a buddy of Al’s
that used to wear this…
I can't say that.
But we go in there and we, I start—
we, and then me in particular, start
buying I think it was Wild Turkey by the bottle.
- Oh, wow.
- And drinking it out of the bottle.
It was ugly.
So let's just say
that it wasn't long after that, my head
was hanging out the
the window of the limo, getting sick,
and all these guys were laughing at me,
and thank God it was pre-iPhone.
Otherwise
I could never live it down.
I still can't live it down
with these guys.
- So who's like the comfort in the group
at that moment?
Like, was Dirk like, “It's OK, Mark.”
- Hell no. Are you kidding me?
Are you kidding me?
They're like, oh, they were
throwing me under the bus for years.
For years.
But, you know, that's the exception
that proves the rule.
- Yeah, no.
Totally.
Because, you know, I was like,
you got to have the friend
that, like, holds your hair back
if you got to throw up.
- Oh, my God.
- You gotta have that one.
But I think, yeah, guys are different.
They get on each other,
like, “You can't hang.”
It’s definitely a different thing.
- Yeah.
The good news is I got worse
stories on Dirk and all those guys, so.
- Yeah, so you have that as blackmail.
If you did iPhone it,
don't ever show cuz I got you, Dirk.
- Absolutely.
- Dirk is so fun.
Like, I genuinely really like Dirk.
- He’s a good dude.
- He's just, like, a nice guy.
- I love him to death. He's a great guy.
- Yeah.
- Great guy. A heart of gold.
Just says the dumbest, funnest—
You know, he's just a good dude.
You can’t say enough great things.
- So it's super
clear to me that, like, the relationships
that you have are important to you.
And obviously relationships are important
in any business.
It's one of the things that makes business
men and women very successful.
But I feel like relationships in
the NBA can be hard
because it is such a business
and everybody has, like, one thing
that they're trying to accomplish.
Is there anyone that has been
in the league that you would like to mend
a relationship with?
- Golly, that's a great question.
I mean, it was rocky with Steve Nash
for a while after he left,
and I'd like to think we'd mended that.
We hung out a couple of
times and talked,
and I think we're on the same page.
You know, I think we could have parted
ways with Monta Ellis a little better way.
You know, it was—
things just changed
and that created issues.
And I think I didn't handle it
as well as I could’ve.
Like, you're going to make mistakes.
- Yeah.
- And the other hard part is
generations are different.
You know, when I first came into the league,
we were still on the tail
end of the macho generation and the league
was telling AI how to dress
and so having a dress code and all that.
And then in the 2010s, you know,
the older millennials, I guess, now were,
you know, approached basketball different.
And you just started to see
the advent of social media and Facebook
and the like.
And, you know, but ESPN and TV
were still really, really big.
And then,
you know, kids coming in Luka’s generation—
Zion, Ja—it's all social media.
- Yeah.
- They grew up completely driven,
not necessarily driven,
excuse me,
but they grew up, you know, organically
with social media. It was, you know,
they were stars when they were teenagers,
you know,
teenagers coming into the NBA. You know,
they could have been stars when they were
11, 12, 13 years old.
And so, you know, they're very much
more cognizant of their brand,
and it's going to get even worse
now with NIL. You're going to have kids
making so much money
in high school and college.
Pros may not be increase in pay,
you know? But the point being that
generations in this game
change, and teams have to adapt,
and relationships have to adapt.
And, you know, when I was as young
as some of the players, it was easy.
- Yeah.
- Now it’s harder, you know, because they look at me
and like, “OK that's just the owner dude.”
- Right. Yeah.
I mean, I could tell
even when I asked and you were,
you were thinking about it,
and you mentioned Steve and Monta.
Are those things that you think about now
still?
- Not as much.
I mean, because he gets consumed
with what's going on and what's in
front of you.
- Yeah.
What would you have done differently?
With Steve, I would have kept him.
With Monta,
I just remember having a meeting with him,
and I just,
I just don't think I handled it
as well as I could, because Monta,
you know, I think he's a good guy
with a great heart.
- Yeah, no. Absolutely.
I mean, I think that just in general, like,
owners can be put in these, like,
very sticky situations
cuz you're having to manage
so many different things at all times
to the best of your ability.
And like, just, you know, the,
the example that, that I'll use
is everything
that's happening in Brooklyn, right?
You, like, have to do the right thing
because one wrong move,
it might mess everything up.
- The hard part is
I think that people don't realize is
you don't buy a team
to take on a job, right?
I didn’t buy the Mavs
because I wanted a job.
- Yeah.
- I bought the Mavs
because I was done having jobs.
- Yeah. That’s true. Yeah.
- You know?
I bought the Mavs because I love basketball
and, you know, I love the Mavericks.
I was a season ticket holder,
and I wanted to see them do better,
and I wanted to enjoy it.
And you wanna hire people to
do the things, and you hope it works out.
The hard part is when you make mistakes
where it doesn't work out.
- Yeah.
- Right?
Because, you know, your name's on the check.
- Mmhmm.
- And it's your ultimate responsibility.
And, you know, whether it's Brooklyn
or whoever is put in those circumstances,
you know, the owner is not involved
because they wanna be involved.
- Right.
- They're involved because it's fallen on them
to have to be involved.
- Yeah.
Cuz that's the thing
like with Brooklyn, right?
Like how do you navigate being the story?
Like, when what everyone is talking about
the team, it's you, like,
the owner is the story.
Does that make sense?
- No, it makes total sense.
And it really depends on who the owner is.
- Yeah
- You know,
I'm used to being famous, right?
But being famous can be hard.
- Mmhmm.
- And being famous is even harder
when you don't wanna be.
- Yeah.
- You know, when you don't
wanna be the center of attention,
and you just wanna enjoy your life,
enjoy your team and,
you know, enjoy the game.
And, you know, I don't know
Joe [Tsai] that well.
I'm gettin' to know him better.
I don't know why, but
I never asked him why he bought the team
or what's the importance of it to him.
- Yeah.
- It may be
because his kids love basketball.
Maybe it's because, you know,
he wants a legacy business to turn over
to, you know, a son or daughter
who may love basketball.
You don't really know the reasons why.
And so when you're in that position,
and all of a sudden,
you know, it's
social media is just on fire, you know,
and you can't really go
and look because it's just brutal.
- Yeah.
- Right?
It's really, you know, there's
no real easy way to deal with it.
- Mmhmm.
- You know, and, look, you also have to
give yourself a reality check.
It's first-world problems.
- Totally.
- Right?
- Oh, my team that I own
is going through some issues.
- I mean, I've been broke, and having people
yell at me because the Mavs are doing so
well is a whole lot
better than being broke, you know?
- Yeah.
- You know, eatin' mustard and ketchup
sandwiches was—
- Was not it.
- Yeah I'll take, you know,
"Sell the team you, S—, F—," whatever.
You know, I can live with that,
but it takes some time to get used to.
- Yeah, for sure.
And I just think so
much of it is, like, just navigating things
on all different levels.
And so you've mentioned, like, social media a bunch.
What is your relationship
with social media?
- Yeah, it's fun
cuz I've got a lot of different
personalities for social media, right?
There's what I do with Cost Plus Drugs, there's
what I do for entrepreneurs, there's what I do
with Shark Tank and what I do with the Mavs.
- Yeah.
- And there's different levels of response
in each of those,
you know. Shark Tank's all friendly,
you know, or "Why did you do this deal?"
"You suck," whatever.
Or, you know, "I didn't like the product."
"Why did you invest," whatever.
Um, that stuff's easy.
Um, technology
and entrepreneurship is easy,
even though people may disagree with you.
But NBA Twitter can be brutal.
- Yeah, it can.
- Brutal.
And you just gotta realize that,
you know,
you know, fan is short for fanatic,
you know?
- Mmhmm.
- And that's what I remind myself.
The people who are most belligerent
or mean or evil or whatever—
- Yeah.
- You wanna think that they're the ones
who love the Mavs or their team the most.
- Mmhmm.
- And so I always, you know,
try to put that in context, but, you know,
and it's the worst during the summer,
because everybody wants to win the summer.
- Yeah.
- It's not about winning
championships, right?
It's about winning the summer.
"Well, so-and-so did this,"
And "This guy hasn't signed a deal yet,"
or "This guy hasn't done that."
- Yeah.
- And, "So why aren't you doing something?"
"You piece of da-da-da-da-da."
You know, like, you know, it's funny
because there was a guy, and I happened
to be looking at my timeline, right?
Cuz I was looking at Cost Plus Drug stuff.
And in my timeline, his
his handle was, "F Mark Cuban, sell the Mavs."
And there's a lot of them,
it wasn't like there was just one.
- Yeah.
- But this guy was really coming hard.
So he had his DMs open,
and so I just sent him a DM saying,
"I love you, too. Have a nice day,"
just because, you know, it's just like—
- Yeah. Did he respond?
- No, no.
- Is that still his name?
- I don't know. Yeah,
it still's his name.
- Oh, it is.
- Yeah, still his name.
But it happens all the time, like—
- Yeah.
- Like, when I was—
I said something last year about how,
you know, insane Mavs Twitter can be,
and then, you know,
I went and offered a bunch of those people tickets.
- Mmhmm.
- Because, you know,
what happens is people
use it as a platform to blow off steam,
and it's a way for them to create,
you know, a community.
There's, like—there's a community
for every team of the fans
that hate everything
the front office does.
- Yes.
- Right?
They love their best players.
They hate their worst players.
And—but it's a community.
And when you actually talk to them,
they're not really mean and nasty.
- Mmhmm.
- It's just Twitter.
- Right.
- You know—
- I always—like, the internet's not a real place.
- No, Twitter's not real.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Not real life.
- It's not a real place.
- So I try to give 'em a little love.
- Yeah.
- And then they back down,
and then they—
So, there's this one
podcast/website, and I'm like, "Well,
just have me on," and have me on,
ask me nothing but benign,
easy, simple questions, right?
At the end of it, I'm like, "You
sure there's nothing else you wanna add?"
- Yeah.
- And then he gets back on Twitter,
just crushes me every day.
I'm like, dude—
- You had your opportunity.
- You had your chance.
- Yeah, that is so funny.
And also, too, with the internet,
I always trusted people. I'm like,
all you have to do is get to the next day
cuz no one cares.
- No one cares. That's the thing.
The news cycles are so short.
- Yeah.
- And people don't, you know, do their homework.
They don't really care care.
- Right.
- It's not like people dig in to find out
all the details and everything.
They just wanna talk crap, right? And
more power to 'em.
- It's, like, whatever.
Yeah, go ahead.
- Better you talking about the NBA
than talking about whoever?
- Yeah. OK.
So you tweeted about the play-in
tournament, speaking of Twitter.
- Uh huh.
- You talked about the injuries.
- First, I wanna ask how you
would restructure the plan,
but also I wanna know what changed
because you did push for the plan.
- No,
So, first of all, you know,
leading into restarting the league
was one set of circumstances.
So the plan was a good idea.
And then as we got into it,
it wasn't so much that the play-in—
So then we were playing in a season
that was shortened and was off schedule, right?
- Mmhmm.
- It wasn't a normal schedule.
So the plan had a different set
of circumstances as well.
Then we get to this year,
and it's like that ninth and 10th team
in both conferences
had some really bad teams, right?
- Mmhmm.
- And you had this unexpected
set of circumstance, unintended
consequences, where you had teams
not only trying to get the best draft
pick, but trying to avoid the plan.
- Yeah.
- And you created these circumstances
where you had to make a choice
between having a top-six, seven
or eight pick,
you know, maybe ninth pick
or making the play-in.
And if you don't have a decent team,
and you're a six, seven, eight,
nine pick is gonna really help you—
- Mmhmm.
- You might sandbag a play-in game.
- So that was my attitude there.
And so what I proposed,
and they turned it down,
was that we go back to what we did
in the bubble where you had to be
I think it was in four games,
within four games—
- Yeah.
- In order to make the play-in,
which I thought is great.
- Mmhmm.
- Right.
But being ten or 11 games back,
and look what happened to the Clippers.
They lose Paul George to COVID for one game.
- Mmhmm.
And it, yeah.
- You're out.
- So that's how you would restructure,
go back to how they did the bubble.
- Yeah, that's exactly what I suggested.
- It's not that you're like, "No plan."
- No.
- You're just like, there's a different way.
- Yeah, you have—context always matters.
- Yeah.
- And so now
we're back to a regular live season
for the most part, 82 games.
- Mmhmm.
- And so, you know, I was a proponent
of making it within four games,
but they shot me down.
- Yeah, well, the thing is,
and I know this isn't, like, your argument,
but what somebody would just say is
like, "Well, then don't be in the bottom."
- Well—
- You know.
- Yeah, you know,
I wish you can control injuries.
- Yeah.
- I wish I could control all the other
teams and trades and all that.
But you can't.
- OK.
Well, I mean, so
as we're kind of sticking with Twitter
and things that you've tweeted
and just the platform in general,
I have to say this. So,
I remember so vividly
where I was in 2015
when the emoji battle happened
with DeAndre Jordan.
- Oh.
- And everybody—
- I was like, "What is she talking about?"
To me, that was like the
first big NBA Twitter moment,
cuz just if everyone was talking about it.
I know what I remember about that night,
but what do you remember about that night?
- I remember sitting in the lobby
of a hotel in Houston, and
what made it
memorable wasn't so much
what was going on with DeAndre
as much as the guy
who was working in the hotel
lobby was, you know,
Bjelica, the guy who played
for the Warriors last year.
- Mmhmm, yeah.
- His younger brother was, like,
the 6-foot-8 guy working the lobby.
- [Laughing]
- And I'm like, that is just the weirdest thing ever that
this guy's, you know.
And sitting there with Dan Fegan—
rest in peace, Dan—and
wondering what the hell is going on.
And Dan was his agent. And there was also
DeAndre, some guy named Steve
something that was there.
And we couldn't figure out
what was going on.
- Mmhmm.
- And that was it.
No driving around,
none of that stuff,
- Yeah.
- right?
And it was just like,
we can't get a hold of him, you know?
Obviously something's changed,
and moving on.
- Yeah, cuz I'm like, well,
how does that legend begin,
right?
Everyone's like,
Mark Cuban's driving around
downtown, begging for his address.
But now it's, like, a thing
that has stuck with you,
even though you have said,
"This isn't what happened."
- Yeah, yeah.
But, like, when you started saying 2015,
it didn't even register that that was what you
were going to bring up.
- Yeah, you're like, "What?"
Yeah.
- So yeah, that's,
you know, under the bridge.
But yeah, at the time it was like,
oh, my goodness, this is insane.
- Yeah.
- You know, and I was pissed,
but you gotta move on, right?
It's a business,
- Yeah.
- you know, and players
get to make their choices.
And I understand why the Clippers did it
because it would have had a huge impact
on their team.
- Yeah, absolutely.
I know, cuz I'm like, OK,
so it was just, like, a clubhouse
in his house,
and all these Clippers were here.
And then Blake Griffin is, like, tweeting
funny photos of the chair.
- Yeah, well, that's Blake, right?
- Yeah. And like, it was just so funny.
But it's interesting
for you to be like,
"I don't even know what you were talking about,"
when to all of us, it was this huge night.
- It was more interesting to me when I was
pile-driving Blake at a party after 2013
All-Star before, I think it was 2013
All-Star Game.
- Uh huh.
- You can ask him about it someday.
- OK.
[Laughing]
I will.
When I talk to Blake, I'm
going to say, "Hey, Mark, tell me a story
that I want you to expand on."
All right,
sticking with Twitter.
You and Lil Wayne friends?
- Yeah.
- OK, good.
- Yeah, we're good.
- So I know it, like, Mack Maine said that
y'all talked
- Yeah.
- and you're cool now. Cuz that was,
like, a very out-of-left-field situation.
- That was weird.
But, yeah, because it pissed him off,
as he told me, because his son
was in the picture, and his son's mom
didn't like the idea of his son being
visible like that.
- Gotcha.
- Which I understood,
Right?
- Mmhmm.
- So we had a conversation
during the Phoenix game,
and I actually got him
the tickets for him to come.
- That's fun.
- But I went up and said hi, met his son.
He goes, his son's
a huge fan of "Shark Tank."
And so we talked for a little bit,
and it was cool.
It was over.
- Yeah.
You know why?
Because internet's not a real place.
- It's not a real, it's no big deal. And Wayne
and I have known each other—
- Yeah.
So you can see someone in person and be like,
"Oh, we're cool."
Like, it's not that big of a deal. Yeah,
everyone's like,
"Lil Wayne and Mark Cuban?"
- Yeah, I was a little bit that way too.
Cuz I thought I was pretty damn
funny to pull,
you know,
- Yeah.
- Cuz one of the songs, "Uproar,"
is, like, a song we always play when
Daymond John's on the set.
That's a song we always play
prior to shooting.
- Yeah.
- Right? And we all get hyped,
and we all know the words.
And this and that.
So pulling out a line from that song was
easy.
- Yeah.
- Easy.
I mean, it was perfect.
- Yeah.
- Like, it fit perfectly, so.
So when I
was researching for this interview,
I saw you, like, sort of touch
on something that I never knew
that I would love for you to expand on.
You were saying that in 2007,
there was a moment
where you were almost trading for Kobe?
- Yeah, I thought it was done.
- Please tell me that story.
- So,
I was in "Dancing with the Stars,"
and we practiced a lot,
like seven, eight hours a day,
cuz I needed it.
And I was going back and forth with Dr.
Buss, and he had, I forget who called who.
I think he called me actually
and said, look,
we think we might be parting ways
with Kobe.
And I remember it vividly
because there was a PA named Elvis
who was working on set. It was just Lakers,
Lakers, Lakers, Lakers, Lakers.
And I used to give him a hard time.
- Yeah.
- He'd give me a hard time.
And we had just gone to the Finals
the year before and this and that. And so,
we just talked Kobe, and he was Kobe,
Kobe, Kobe all the time, you know,
with this guy. "Kobe," you know.
So it started to happen,
- Yeah.
- and I started telling him about it.
And that was the kiss of death.
Cuz the minute I told Elvis,
it all fell apart.
- Oh, no. Why did it fall apart?
- Because I guess Mitch
Kupchak talked Kobe into staying,
you know.
- Wow.
- It was just like DeAndre.
Not the same, same.
But, you know,
- Yeah.
- when a guy
that's key to your team wants to leave,
you're gonna do everything you can to keep him.
- So what would this, like,
Kobe Mavs team have looked like?
- It would have been damn good.
- Yeah.
- You know, and Dirk was like,
I would have traded me for Kobe.
- And I'm like, no, I'm not gonna trade you,
Dirk. That's the whole point, right?
- Wow.
- Yeah, we would've been something else.
- And it's crazy to
just think about all the things
that would have changed if that trade…
- Yeah, you just never know.
- Yeah.
- You just never know.
- Wow. Oh, my gosh. That's crazy.
- And then they trade for Pau Gasol,
and life's different.
It's just, the NBA,
you're just one, you know,
sprained ankle or trade or who knows what,
and everything changes.
- Yeah. But,
like, when you say you were close,
you're like, we were at the finish line,
but he had—
- I thought it was done.
I thought it was done, yeah.
- Like,
- Done.
- it's done,
- 2007, Kobe's coming.
- Done.
Like, let's start talking
about putting together the trade call.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
- But so,
but when you think of that moment,
you're like, OK, well,
like, the Mavs were OK,
but are you like, wow,
it would have been really beautiful
if that worked?
- Never, never.
- Really?
- Never have thought that one time.
- OK.
- Not even one time. Cuz you can't.
- Yeah, you can't.
- Yeah.
- Oh, my God. I'd be thinking about it
every day. Like, oh, my gosh.
Elvis is probably still…
- Yeah, he's hyped about it. No, Elvis is like,
"I changed it.
I changed the karma. That's
what you get for telling me, you dumbass."
- I know. Elvis is probably,
like, no longer a Lakers fan.
He's like—shoutout to Elvis. Where is Elvis?
- I don't know. I don't know.
But he still thinks I'm a dumbass
for telling him.
- Yeah, like that was, that was it. Wow.
I mean, that's,
yeah, that was a really good story.
I'm like, how is, I've never heard
you talk about it. It was, like,
buried somewhere very low, and I was like,
I've never heard you.
So no, thank you for…
- Yeah, it was right there.
I thought it was done.
- Yeah.
- And I thought, this is great.
I just beat Floyd Mayweather
in "Dancing with the Stars,"
right? He'd been eliminated.
I'm like, I'm rolling.
- [Laughing] Yeah.
- I am the king, baby.
This is—nope.
And that's just life.
That's business, right?
- Yeah.
- That's the NBA.
That's the real business world.
You think you got a deal closed, and
it's not done until they sign on the line
that is dotted, you know.
- Yeah.
So are you a person that has regrets or
no?
-  I've had a few.
I'm not somebody
who really looks back and says, OK,
I would have done all this differently.
- Right.
- Cuz things have worked out
pretty damn well,
- Right.
- you know?
- I'd say so.
- Yeah. And so, you know, not so much.
- OK.
- You know, more than anything, it's like,
OK,
I probably should have spent more time
at that princess party with my daughter
- Mm.
- instead of rolling my eyes, you know,
- Yeah.
- that type of thing. You know,
but that's just the way it works.
- Well, now you get to do
TikToks with your daughter, so.
- Yeah, well, she does, not anymore cuz she's
going off,
- OK.
- she's getting ready to go to college.
And even my middle daughter,
they're not, you know, TikToks
isn't so much dances anymore.
So that kind of really hurt me.
- Yeah, you're like,
wait a minute. I need to dance.
- Oh, whoa, you know?
- [Laughing]
What's your favorite TikTok dance?
- Oh, my God.
- You better make your kids proud
with this answer.
- No,
The Weeknd song ♪♪♪ dun, dun, dun,
dun, dun ♪♪♪
was one that was really good.
And…I don't know.
Just go mcuban on TikTok.
You see all my greatest hits.
- Oh, yeah,
I'll check the tape.
- But my son's, like, really into cooking now.
- Oh, wow.
- And so we'll do cooking
TikToks, yeah. But he's really bummed
cuz they booted him off
cuz he wasn't 13 yet.
- Oh, no.
- So he's about to turn 13.
And so there's nothing more exciting
to him
- Yeah.
- than being back and getting his own
TikTok account again.
- I love that.
You know one of my favorite things?
It's, like, nothing makes Dad light up
other than talking about their kids.
- Oh, there's nothing better, right?
- Yeah.
- It really is beautiful.
And how many do you have, actually?
- I've got three.
- Three.
- My oldest is getting ready
to go to college this weekend.
- Oh.
- So that's gonna be brutal.
- Where?
- Vanderbilt.
- Oh, wow.
- Jerry Stackhouse town.
- Yeah.
- So I get a chance to visit Stack.
- I love that.
- He's a great coach.
And so, yeah, that's, it's kind of mixed
emotions, you know. She's like,
"Get me the hell outta here."
- [Laughing]
- My wife and I are like, [groaning].
- Yeah, cuz, I mean, this is your, like, first one
- First one.
- you're sending off.
I feel like two and three will maybe get
a little easier cuz you've done it?
- I don't know. I don't know.
But
- Yeah.
- she's kicking us to the curb.
[Laughing]
- Yeah, that's what,
that's how it goes.
I remember when I went to school, I'm like,
I love y'all so much,
- I know.
- but I'll catch ya at Thanksgiving.
- See ya.
- Yeah, I'll see you there.
- I was the same way. I'm like,
"Let's gooo!"
You know?
- Yeah.
- That's my daughter.
- But I always say it's like,
so that first month she'll call y'all,
like, every other day
cuz she'll miss you.
She'll be like, this is different.
- No.
- I don't have friends yet.
- But then it will fade.
- No.
- You won't get many calls.
- Not my daughter. My daughter is gonna be like I was.
[Excited screaming]
- [Laughing] Yeah, like immediately.
- Look at all these people! My parents aren't here.
Let's gooo!
- That's so fun. Good for her.
I hope she has…
- My daughter's got,
like, 17 fake IDs lined up.
OK,
for each one, it's like, how many weekends
do I come back to Dallas?
Because as each one gets taken from me.
- Yeah.
- Cuz they're stricter in Nashville.
Right?
"I've gotta back up."
- She's gotta re-up. Really?
- Dad,
I'm planning for college, right?
- Yeah.
[Laughing]
Oh, my gosh.
- My freshman year I, it was, like, 3 a.m.
I am drunk out of my mind.
Freshman year.
- You drink?
- I call my—
[Laughing] Yeah,
no. I have had a few.
I call my parents drunk, and I'm like,
you guys, I made a big mistake.
And they're like,
"Do we need to come to Illinois right now?"
I'm like, "No, I just need to let you know
I'm really drunk."
You know, my mom's so dramatic.
She's like,
"Make sure you sleep on your side.
Where's your roommate? I need—"
Like, she stayed on the phone with me
that night.
- [Laughing]
- I'm like, why did I call my parents
and tell them this?
- No!
Oh, man.
- I hope that doesn't happen to you.
You don't get any calls.
- No, maybe my—
No, not any of them, actually.
- Yeah.
- They're all pretty damn independent.
- It was, I truly, like,
I do not know why I did that.
It's, it was a bad memory.
And she brings it up all the time, so.
- I bet.
- Yeah, but she's gotta let that go.
- The good news is that was the
one time you got drunk.
- Yeah, I have never been drunk ever again.
- You learned your lesson.
- You know, I didn't get "Mark,
Dirk, Steve Nash in the limo" drunk.
- [Blowing raspberry] Wild Turkey drunk?
- [Laughing] Yeah, Wild Turkey drunk.
I do wanna go back to something too.
You talked about Dr.
Buss, and I read somewhere you said that
he has been the most influential owner
to you.
- By far.
- Like, you've learned the most from him.
- I did, yeah.
- What have you learned?
- I mean, because I was getting in trouble
all the time with David Stern.
And so,
- Yeah.
- you know, he was amazing.
He would come
to Dallas. He'd invite me over,
and we'd talk.
And basically, it was, like, "Mark,"
and he'd give me this list of things
he's done where "David didn't like this,
the NBA didn't,
hated me for that.
The NBA changed the rules for this.
Just be you."
- Mhm.
- "And if you're you, things will work out."
- Yeah.
- And that was the best advice I got.
And that's the rule I followed.
- And they have worked out.
- They have.
- Yeah.
Would you say you are a bit of a troublemaker?
- I like to disrupt.
- Mm.
- Right?
I mean, it's not so much him trying
to cause trouble just to cause trouble.
But if I think there's a better way,
I'm not gonna be shy.
- Yeah. Cuz you are a person,
and correct me if I'm wrong,
it feels like you always say
exactly what you're thinking.
- No. [Laughing]
- No? [Laughing]
- Trust me, it'd be a lot worse
if I did.
- You give a, like,
a little purer version?
- It, I won't just say something.
People say, you know,
the world has changed over
the last 20 years,
right? Obviously.
But if I think I can have an impact,
I'll say it.
- Mmhmm.
- And if I think I can have an impact
by doing something, I'll do it.
But now with my kids being older,
right, and having to deal with it
more, yeah,
I probably hold some things back
- Yeah.
- that I wouldn't have when I first got here.
Do you know how much money you've had
to pay in fines?
- No.
- You're like, "But it's a lot of money"?
Yeah, you're like, it's a lot.
But I read somewhere that when you do get
fined, you match the money
- Yeah, I donate to charity.
- and donate it.
- Yeah.
- So keep getting fined.
- Yeah. [Laughing]
- And I haven't the last couple years
simply because, you know,
I told some of the officials, I'm like,
you guys have struggled with COVID too.
So I'm going to take it easy on you.
- Yeah.
- But this coming year, it's on.
- Yeah, it's back. I'm back talking.
I love that.
OK, a couple more for you before
we go to some fan questions
- Uh huh.
- and close out.
Patrick Mahomes said that you are
somebody that he watches a lot
and, like, learns a lot from.
- Uh huh.
- What do you think is the potential
of Patrick Mahomes as a businessman?
- Oh, he's great actually.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, no, he's super smart.
He understands that you have to be diversified.
He understands that the concept of
community. He understands that, you know,
you have to know what you know
and know what you don't know.
And so it's been great.
- Yeah.
- So, you know, he comes to Mavs games,
and he'll come back at halftime.
And we'll sit, and we'll talk.
- Mmhmm.
- And so, yeah, I'm
sure we'll do things together.
- Yeah. OK,
what do you think is one thing that he
should be doing that he hasn't done yet?
- I don't know.
I mean, I don't,
we haven't gotten in enough detail.
- Mmhmm.
- But he knows that he can email me
with any questions he has,
and I'll give him—like, for all of our guys,
I tell them,
if you have any business questions,
happy to help.
- Absolutely. OK.
So I'm a "Billions" fan.
- Uh huh?
- So I have seen actor Mark,
you know, every now and then.
Which, by the way, you're pretty good.
- Of course I am.
- Yeah.
- Did you not see me in "Sharknado 3"?
[Both laughing]
- The Oscar-winning "Sharknado 3."
Yeah, I'm like,
wait, it doesn't even really feel like,
you know, sometimes after cameos,
- Yeah.
- I'm like, this is a cameo.
They've, like, given you real lines and—
- Yeah, real stuff to do.
Yeah, they're bringing me back.
Yeah, so that's even better.
- Oh, I love it.
OK, very good.
Very good.
OK, so my thing about shows like
"Billions" or "Succession" or whatever, how
accurate of a depiction are those shows of, like,
what—
- "Billions" can be accurate. "Succession,"
I remember starting to watch with
my wife.
- Yeah.
- I'm like, God help us if
that's our family, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- If we have messed up that bad that
our kids
go that wrong, just, I just,
oh, my God.
- Yeah.
- I actually did a podcast with Kara Swisher
on it, and we were talking about it.
I'm like, no, that, no.
I mean, I know other wealthy families.
- Mmhmm.
- And there's some, like,
really messed up people but not that bad.
- Yeah.
- Not that bad.
- Yeah, it's bad in "Succession."
- Yeah, there's just like, no way.
- Yeah.
- I mean, yeah, I'd cut my kids out,
you know?
- Yeah, it's like, I got to save you
from yourself in this moment.
So what you said, "Billions" is, like,
fairly accurate.
- Yeah.
- Like, give me an example
where you're like, "Oh, this is a thing, like,
that happens."
- There's some, you know, swinging
you know what between people on Wall
Street in particular
- Yeah.
- that, you know, wanna try to, like,
the only people I've ever met
that can't get enough money
even though they have a lot are people on
Wall Street.
- Mmhmm.
- You know, where it's like a scorecard for them,
which I get at a certain extent, but
there's a point of diminishing returns.
- Yeah.
- You know, and where that, your next dollar
is not going to change anything
about your life or your kid's life
or their kids or their kids' lives.
But yet they want to keep on proving
that they can make more,
more, more money.
- Yeah.
- And they'll do stupid stuff just to get there.
And that's kind of, that was incredibly
accurately portrayed in "Billions."
- Mmhmm.
- And, you know, some of the
the backstabbing,
you know, I've seen that happen too.
- Yeah, OK.
- But I stay away from all that stuff.
- Yeah, no, for sure. I mean, great show.
I mean, I'm kind of sad that, like,
they've lost many of the characters.
- Yeah. I mean, losing Damian is a lot, right?
- Yeah, I'm like, ehh.
I don't, like, love Mike Prince.
But it's still a good show.
- Mike, no, Mike, he's done a good job,
right?
- Yeah, he's a great actor.
- Yeah.
- But I'm like, it's not the same.
- It's not the same as Damian.
- It's just really not the same.
- Yeah, Ax is something special.
- Yeah, absolutely.
What role do you think billionaires
should play in terms
of making the world better?
- I mean, I'm not going to tell someone else
what to do with their money.
- Yeah.
- Everybody's got to decide who they are.
But I think it really comes down
to how you define capitalism.
You know, to me, capitalism
isn't about how much money can you make.
Capitalism means how much impact can you make.
You know how, if you can be an entrepreneur
and start a company,
where do you get your satisfaction?
And satisfaction can come from,
you know, how much money do you have.
It can come from, you know,
how much have you changed the world.
It can come from,
you know, how have you changed the lives
of seven people
that were important to you?
- Mmhmm.
- You know, but that's the beauty of a capitalist system.
The bad side is
I think we've defined it for
so many people that it's just about money.
- Yeah.
- You know, it's not about impact.
And that's one of the reasons
I do "Shark Tank."
Because we send the message
that the American dream is alive and well.
And I try,
I personally try to send the message that,
you know, a company can have incredible
amounts of impact on people.
I did a deal last year with Erica
and this company called No Limbits.
L-I-M-B-I-T-S.
And she has a prosthetic leg,
and she started creating fashion
for people with prosthetics.
It's just, you know, and it's small now,
but it's going [steadily accelerating thrumming].
- Yeah.
- And every single one of her customers,
she's impacting their lives
and making it better.
- Mmhmm.
- You see that every time with businesses.
And so to her, to me and to many others,
capitalism is your opportunity
to use your own skills
and use your own, to grind it in
your way to have an impact.
- Mmhmm.
- And, you know,
to me, that's the way to go.
But I'm not going to tell somebody else
how to go.
- Yeah. Well, one thing that is, you know,
really cool about following you is
you'll retweet people that have been
impacted by Cost Plus Drugs.
- Yeah.
- And I, like, admittedly wasn't
as educated about this gap in what
the pay is, like, what it actually costs
versus what they charge you.
- Yeah, for drugs, yeah.
- And it is, like, insane.
- It's insane. It's insane. Yeah.
- Yeah, like I didn't know that—
- And that's why they've been able to do it
because people really don't understand.
- Yeah.
- They've been really, you know,
the traditional pharmaceutical industry
and more.
There's like these three or four companies
that are just enormous.
They own insurance companies,
they own retail pharmacies,
they own these things called pharmacy
benefit managers,
and they just distort the hell
out of the pricing of drugs, you know?
And so, we got in there, Dr.
Alex Oshmyanky, my partner
and I, created CostPlusDrugs.com.
And part of the goal is really simple.
We want to be the low-cost provider
of every single FDA-approved
medication that exists.
And we're gonna do it
through complete transparency.
So when you go to CostPlusDrugs.com,
we have more than a thousand drugs now.
And you put in the drug that you use,
and not only are you gonna see the price
we charge, which more often than not
is gonna be
less than you can get anywhere else,
maybe even less than your co-pay.
But you also see our cost, and you'll see
what we pay, what Cost Plus Drugs pays.
You'll see that we mark it up 15 percent.
That's it.
$3 pharmacy handling
fee, and $5 for shipping.
That's it. And so, you know what we pay.
And so, you know there's not
you know, we're being fair about it.
And that builds trust
and we've just, it's just exploded.
- Yeah.
- You know, like you said,
the things that people have put on
social media have just been incredible,
the lives that we've changed.
- Mhm.
- And, you know, you can't get enough of it.
You know, I literally, I love to go now
and, you know, search for CostPlusDrugs.com-
- Yeah.
- on Twitter, because like I just tweeted
one yesterday or this morning
where a lady was spending 3,000-plus
dollars a month for a drug,
and we cut it down to like $52.
- Yeah.
- It's crazy.
- No, yeah.
Like, so, my sister is a Type 1 diabetic,
and she always talks to me
about how much insulin costs-
- Cost of insulin, yeah.
- Like, I'll get that for her
and all of these things.
And she was saying that, you know,
she might be potentially moving to Buffalo
for work or whatever.
And she's like, 'But it'd be great,
because insulin is cheaper in Canada.'
So I'm like, "Wait a minute,
no, no, no, no, no."
- Yeah. It's crazy.
- "We're not having to travel to Canada
for you to get this."
- Yeah. We're trying to change that.
Yeah, it's wild that these things, like,
you shouldn't have to pay so much
to be healthy.
Like, just to live. Like, if you're
diabetic, you literally need insulin.
But people are marking it up-
- No, for sure. No question.
- It's just wild to me.
- You know, and there's multiple prices,
and there's games that are played with these
things called average wholesale pricing.
And, you know,
wholesale acquisition cost. It's just a joke
the way they do it.
And so, stay tuned on insulin. We're
doing our best to try to have an impact there.
- Ayy, I love it.
OK, I'm gonna make sure I tell her-
- Tell her to sign up.
- Yeah, no, I love that.
OK, so to close out, I want to play peak
and the pit with you.
- OK.
- I need you to tell me your peak of this year
and your pit of this year.
So your favorite moment and
your not-so-favorite moment.
- Um, favorite was beating Phoenix Game 7.
- Yeah.
- Not-so-favorite was losing to Golden State.
Not even in Game 5
where we're eliminated, but
we had a couple games where we were way
up and we couldn't hold on.
And so those were real valleys of... [Laughing]
- Yeah.
So you're like, OK, we got to come back
next year and get it done. [Laughing]
- Yeah, bigger, better, stronger.
- Absolutely.
- Uh, Rocky, do we have any questions from the app?
- [Off-screen speaker]: Yeah.
A lot of people would like to know
who you would have traded for Kobe.
- Who I would have traded for Kobe?
And I've told... it was Jet, Josh Howard,
I forget who else,
and a couple first-round picks.
- Worth it.
- Yeah.
- [Off-screen speaker]: Someone asked,
what's the worst pitch you've ever heard?
- What's the worst pitch you've ever heard?
- So many bad, bad, bad pitches.
One guy pitched me a super high afro
because it would make guys taller,
um, in a bathroom.
Another, like, there was this guy who came on
Shark Tank where he had these little,
he called them tail lights,
where he thought
it'd be really cool
for, particularly women, to go on dates.
And they had these
flashing lights that they could put
on the back of their jeans.
I mean, there's just so many bad ones
that just-
- OK, wait.
Speaking of pitches,
I've heard that sometimes during a game,
a player will pitch you
something on the court.
- Oh yeah, I've gotten pitched every...yeah.
Not everything, but yeah.
- OK, give me, tell me one.
- No, I can't, right?
- But um,
guys all the time
will be at the free-throw line and see me.
They're like, "Cuban, love Shark Tank".
Like, "I got something for you."
But it's always music and clothes.
And like, the two worst businesses
ever: music and clothes.
- And clothes.
- Everybody thinks they've got a cool slogan,
right? "I am the..." you know.
"I-M-T-M, I am the man," right?
Or "I-A-T-M, I am the man," right?
"And I'm gonna put it across clothes,
and we're gonna sell a bunch." I'm like, "No,
we don't need more slogans on clothes."
- Have any free-throw-line
pitches been good?
- No.
- None?
- Wow, that is,
that's very funny.
So, what do you say back?
You're just like, "That's not for me."
- [Chuckling] I'm like,
I'm like trying to distract them, right?
So when the ball goes up-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah. "Miss this and
I'll give you the capital." [Laughing]
- Right, right? "You got it. Done."
- [Laughing] Yeah, that's so funny.
Okay, any more?
- [Off-screen speaker]: Somebody asks,
do you have any good Party Mark
stories with Charles Barkley?
- Oh my God, yes. [Laughing]
- Our coworker. Any Charles Barkley party story.
- The first time I met Charles...
Lots of great, everybody's
got lots of great Charles Barkley stories.
But, uh, I love CB to death.
And the first time I met
him was the All-Star Game in Atlanta,
a year or two after I bought the team,
maybe a year-and-a-half
after I bought the team.
And all these people kept on telling me,
"Charles Barkley wants to meet you.
Charles Barkley wants to meet you."
I'm like, "Great!"
And it was a long-ass night.
And so, I met him,
it must have been six
or seven in the morning.
And he was in the lobby of his hotel
sending people up.
This is back when they had the little mini
bars and the little mini
drinks in the bottles.
And so he was sending people up
to go to their hotel rooms
to bring down their mini bottles
so we could sit there and drink them.
It was hysterical.
- [Laughing] Just compile all the tiny-
- Just piles of...
bam, bam, bam.
- Yeah. That's so funny.
- I love Charles.
- That sounds like our old coworker,
Charles.
- Charles is incredible.
- Any others?
- [Off-screen speaker]: Um, last one.
We have some people that work at Bleacher
who've been there for a long time
and they said, "Do you still want PR to delete the account?
- [Laughing] Because of the Dirk tweet.
- Oh, that thing.
- [Laughing]
- Hey, I'll stand up for my guys.
- No, I love that.
- I'll always stand up for my guys.
Yeah, I remember,
oh, I got so much s--t,
and they got so much grief, too.
- Yeah.
- But, hey, gotta stand up for my guys.
- No, absolutely, as you should.
OK, before we close out, can I get one
party story out of you, one more time?
One more ask.
Any good party story? Who-
- I mean-
- Who was the most fun to party with?
- [Chuckling] I mean, Dirk.
Dirk. [Laughing]
Just so many.
Oh my God.
Like, getting kicked out of restaurants.
- Who got kicked out?
- Dirk and our crew.
There was one time, I won't say
which player, he knows who he is.
We were at Vegas
and he'd had too much to drink and just
blew chow, right?
Like, people everywhere.
But there were cabanas at this place,
and it was kind of an outdoorsy place,
and he just blew. [Laughing]
And the bar guy comes over,
and security comes over,
ready to throw out somebody
for being too drunk.
- Yeah.
- And we've gotta hide Dirk.
And they kicked out the two guys
that were standing next to him
that we had no idea who they were.
There was another time, another player.
[Laughing] We were walking down the Vegas strip.
We had been at Drai's, and we were coming out.
It was like eight in the morning, right?
And his brother decides
to go swimming in the Caesars fountain.
That did not go well.
- [Laughing]
- Not at all.
So there's just a lot of those.
- Vegas seems to be a common thread in these.
- Well, notice
I'm not mentioning myself in any of these.
You know, I'm just...I'm not gonna self-incriminate myself.
- Nah, that's so funny. OK,
hey, I love it.
All the party stories, I'm into.
Thank you so much for your time.
You were great.
- No, It was fun. Yeah, it was fun.
- Thank you. Thank you for coming on.
Thank you for having us in your domain.
Appreciate it.
- [Laughing] Yeah, oh boy.
- Also, Twitter, deep dive, figure out
who he's talking about in these stories.
You know there's Twitter detectives.
- Oh, I know. Yeah, yeah.
- I love it.
- And it's around All-Star Games, too.
All-Star Games
always lead to craziness.
- Yeah. Always trouble, yeah.
Thanks so much, Mark.
- Thanks, Taylor. Enjoyed it.